corbin 18th career start against the
mets four and seven with a 444 era well
packers got the great slider forcing
fastball in the sinker last time out
against the pittsburgh pirates he threw
his slider a lot kept the swings misses
to maximum but it all starts with his
fastball command
corbin throws the strike too tall for
him
bare hand
josh
to josh
that's a great play by that dad right
there
that's a long throw
after you've made the clean pickup
this wasn't hit all that softly too to
bare hand this ball cleanly
boss is bouncing
just great concentration by both guys
be interesting to see how walker works
schwarber who's there's uh walker's
numbers first is toyota numbers and they
speak for themselves there he's just
been absolutely
phenomenal now has three game leading
off
career home runs
might this be number four opposite field
see
you
later
this man is unreal and the nats are on
top
happy father's day indeed
oh another titanic opposite field blast
for college forever 418 feet off the bat
i just want to send a special thank you
to greg
schwarber for bringing the nationals
this amazing lead off hitter
another no doubter for the lefty
kevin pillar will lead off against
patrick corbin let's have their
outfielders on rehab
getting further along as pillar lifts
one out to right chasing soto back he
looks up and it's out of here
kevin pillar with an opposite field home
run it just snuck over the railing into
the seats beyond the scoreboard sixth
home run of the year for pillar and the
mets get even
you don't think of pillars having
opposite field power but he drives one
out to right field against corbin
and the mets
match schwarber's home run with one of
their own
swaying and a miss there's a good sinker
down and away after corbin got to a
two-strike count that's his 56 strikeout
in just over 72 innings
one and two swing and a miss on the
diving slider
patrick corbin tends to get his
strikeouts and punches and he just got
two in a row
ever since he came up with the pirates
he's a scrappy player
now 33 years old and he goes down
swinging on that up and away fastball
and walker's got his first strike out of
the day i don't most baseball players
too
no that's bunted up the third base side
walker gets the out at third
nicely handled by walker and they pick
off castro for the second out so now
robles with his speed at second corbin
at first with two out here schwarber and
he gets curveball hits it back to walker
terrific play and he gets the out
showing off this athleticism there
tywin walker with a neat play to get
himself through the second inning still
tied at one
that'll take care of the a b
first time around the order
the mets go two for nine with a james
mccann single and a kevin pillar solo
home run
swing gonna miss on the breaking ball
that'll do it patrick corbin two
strikeouts in the second two in the
third
and so
giving up three hits so far
thing with fingertips and knuckles going
in there
that's no contest that ball's in center
field
and lindor acted like he was tagging
trey turner
to let trey think the ball was still on
the infield but a pretty easy steal for
trey yeah that's a hit to play by lindor
you know with instant replay
if a finger just slightly comes off the
base he can call you out but good jump
by trey
pitchers know how aggressive josh is
rbi sitting 90 feet away
bell up the middle and the nets
have the lead
fell behind o2
battled
and that's rbi number 27 for the nats
cleanup hitter for uh
to clear stuff away and
get us on the air
the other thing about it is that the
graduates while they were listening to
speeches and celebrating their big day
as pete lost the bat
and uh
where where exactly did this back go
oh no look at that no louie on the carob
he pulled a guillermo well not really i
mean the orme caught it on the fly
two balls two strikes
strike three call alonzo walks away
and he usually likes to fastball down
patrick corbin number five
swing on this
on the slider
[Applause]
corbin again punching the strikeouts
together three in a row
six on the day taiwan walker has not
been nearly as sharp today as we've seen
of late 2-2
swinging to miss strike three good
slider there he struck out castro and he
gets a big out with the bottom of the
order following castro
and now one for nine as corbin goes down
on strikes third strikeout for walker
and that gets us through four in dc with
the meds down two to one
al shorber and some kind of run with
seven home runs now in 13 rbis in ten
games
turns on one low laser right field see
you
later
another two home run game
for the most powerful lead-off man in
baseball
home run number 17.
his second multi-home run game in as
many days it's the nationals three and
the mets won
oh right in there
caught guessing
that's number seven
for patrick corbin oh an interesting
at-bat there from braz that did not
swing once
you have a good memory keith
how can you forget that double play ball
to lindor out at second guerra made the
turn in time and the mets turn their
second double play behind walker today
pete alonso as we start the seventh
inning pete is over for two today two
for 11 in this series facing patrick
corbin who's now retired 10 minutes in a
row breaking ball lifted to left field
back toward the corner that ball is out
of here
pete alonso lofts a home run
his 11th home run of the year to get the
mets back within a run
80
for his career which ties him for 23rd
on the mets all-time home run list with
keith hernandez really
he did it in a lot quicker time too
patrick bourbon has done and he doesn't
look that surprised about it he goes six
plus
can only be the winner or get a no
decision and gets a great hand here's
the pitch
swinging a shot up the middle castro
nice backhand pickup behind the bag
steps on second throws to first it's a
double play
what a play by starlin castro
that one was smashed up the middle he
made a tough backhanded pickup race to
the bag for one fired to first for two
and it was not close
that's the defensive play of the day for
the nationals from starlin castro here's
a moment a lot of nats fans have been
waiting for
for a long
long time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
daddy
[Applause]
i mean did we just turn the clock back
pre-pandemic or what
that ball is drilled deep to left going
back is smith it is
out of here
c
u
off the top of the wall and later
it's kyle schwarber's world
his first career three home run game
got to get current call get up there get
up there they're waiting for you
and again a fly ball to soto
to end the game
well don't look now but the nats are
five games behind the mets they will
gain two
this weekend